[Music]
good afternoon thank you so much for
joining us today we'll be covering antha
storage and how it enables seamless data
management for kubernetes we'll start
with a quick set of introductions my
name is manu quattro i'm the product
manager for
antha storage for google cloud here with
me is Alexi he's part of the engineering
team for anthos storage and we also have
representation from our partner team
Robin Dario and partner we'll be
covering some use cases around how antha
storage is helping customers around
seamless data management from the topics
perspective the areas we want to focus
on is what really is antha storage what
are the key use cases key
functionalities it is delivering getting
into why we think it's a worldly
challenge to be addressed what are the
challenges today with managing stateful
workloads and how we are enabling with
partner ecosystems so a list of water
partners we're working with and how we
are enabling not just internal but
externally how we are meeting customers
where they are with the storage
providers they're working with we'll get
a deep dive into the architecture pieces
getting into what all the moving parts
how are they connected
and eventually the most exciting part is
going to be a demo where you'll be
actually able to see a couple of use
cases around how we take snapshots and
backups and rollback so that's a pretty
packed agenda we'll get started on this
so starting with what what is antar
storage the key goal we're delivering
with anthro storage is we're providing
enterprise-grade storage management
functions for gk workloads whether those
workloads are running on firm or in the
cloud the goal is to be able to extend
the consistent experience the
centralized control agility and
flexibility that Antos brings to the
table to the storage layer and to do
that we're working essentially where our
goal is to provide our customers with a
consistent set of control plain
interfaces where independent of the
vendor that they're using for the data
plane we want to provide a set of API
and interfaces which are consistent and
to enable that we're working with the
community and our partner community also
so a set of partners we were working to
say how do we engage and enroll them to
get that interface adopted much more
widely so it's it's a much more broader
effort integrating with community and
the partners and providing customers
with a seamless consistent experience
for stateful workload management now
getting into a bit more specifics about
what are the key use cases the key
functionality sets we're planning to
deliver the first set of functionality
is to enable stateful workloads what we
really look for is if I have to do
storage management functions especially
enterprise great for advanced functions
like snapshots can I do it in the same
interface that I am managing my
application or for those functions do I
have to go outside and enable those the
goal for us is to enable those functions
in the same interface the same place
where you are managing other application
level functions other pieces we're
looking for here is well if you're
running enterprise applications
especially stateful enterprise
applications how do you manage disaster
recovery for those applications can I
take backups and what even backups means
in that world is it code data and all
together or it's just parts and pieces
at different rates so one of the key
goals is to enable backups in GCS and
then you can rehydrate them either on
frame or in the cloud wherever you
prefer the right place for the workload
and the application moving on with any
stateful applications one of the
challenging parts is upgrades how do we
enable upgrades and what happens before
you take an upgrade so being able to
enable local snapshots of a stateful
application that's another set of
functionality and then of course
security and roll past role based access
is key to any enterprise grade
application or be ready for even
enterprise applications to come onboard
to having a bit more deeper so if you
look at GCP how we enable data
protection on GCP is you can take a
snapshot in a multi regional bucket or a
regional bucket in GCS
which protectors against either regional
failures or no failures across now the
goal is to work with the partner
community so that the backups can be
stored in GCS and depending on the data
locality that the customers service
levels and the compliance pieces allow
you will be able to store those backups
anywhere in GCS either a regional a
multi regional or a specific bucket
they're on so it's a close collaboration
with the partners and the cloud to
enable the backup and restore
functionality now getting a bit around
why we started to solve this problem and
some of the data points we wanted to
share as we're talking to more customers
and partners so with the evolution of
kubernetes have gone from a beginner
enthusiastic phase into enterprise 1.2
and moving towards a 2.2 adoption where
customers are looking at kubernetes not
just for stateless but also for stateful
workloads and part of the reason is they
are looking for can I have a consistent
experience and a standardized platform
for all my applications versus some
different architectures for different
applications and it's a move towards
that consistency and being able to take
the advantage of kubernetes extend to
stateful applications but again as we
get into it some of the basic functions
like key management app consistent
snapshots being able to take cluster
management those are key areas that have
to be addressed consistently across
before we get to that and as we move on
we're looking to add functionality
around observability if I have an SLO
violation how soon can i address that
can I find all the moving parts and pin
them down to say where is the choke
point or how do I address that within a
reasonable time frame and last but not
least is getting into how do we enable
management at scale with a rich set of
you eyes couple of more data points
around there was a Google survey done
before gk customers and there are a lot
of customers around 39% that are looking
for a standard lift and shift of
applications but if you look at the
numbers there is a larger set of
customer
close to 59% they are looking to
modernize the applications on Prem and
then move to the cloud as in when they
become ready versus kind of just moving
that in a cloud and using it as
infrastructure pieces so the our goal
for the anthro storage is to address
that need where customers are looking to
modernize applications on Prem before
they move to the cloud and start scaling
or actually doing migrations whatever
the use case may be now going deeper
into what are the specific challenges
that we see today with stateful
workloads and what are the key
challenges we see is for the most part
the stories that exist today is designed
to be mapped to a host and when you get
into kubernetes world its containers and
applications so bridging that gap has
been a challenge so we're that's where
we're working with the partners to help
enable bridge that gap in a much more
standardized way next we see is
according to a survey that was done by
data dog last year the biggest
difference is also the average life span
of a container an average life span of a
container is two days versus for a VM is
23 days now in that itself that data
point is interesting but what it means
what it means is that can I move my data
at the same pace that my application is
moving can I match that face and if I
don't what risk does it create do I have
the backups do I have the restore points
that if something goes wrong during that
mobility because it is so agile can I
restore my application back in a state
in a consistent state so that's kind of
key to take away from how we are
interpreting that statement now getting
into basic data lifecycle management
correct can I create app consistent
snapshots when I'm running a DB inside
what does it mean to take a nap
consistent snapshot does it mean I take
a snapshot of the data and there is a
separate chain to take a snapshot of
code and config or can I take a
consistent entity with code config and
data and make a snapshot so when I take
a snapshot and I really
I'm assured that I can rehydrate my
application and no components are left
behind so these are some of the issues
we really are seeing more and more
common as customers are trying stateful
applications with kubernetes GK now
getting a bit deeper around what's our
approach to solve this and how we're
solving this are we understand storage
is very personal to what workloads
you're working on it's also depends on
what partners you choose to work on
given your workloads so our intent is to
meet you where you're comfortable with
the vendors that you're comfortable
working with with that spirit we're
working with a large set of vendors and
listed here are some initial set of
initial set of storage technology
partners there you already started
working with and we're engaging to solve
those use cases but this list will grow
over time and our goal is to really meet
with the vendors with the partners that
you're comfortable with which match the
workload that are deployed with the
isolates that you need for that
particular workloads so as we bring the
partners on board we really will also
want to create a level of comfort with
create by creating a certification
process and we're looking essentially as
a for different types of certifications
of validations one could be what we're
developing is an open interface and
partners are welcome to write to that
interface but once they write they can
self qualify it and they can distribute
it through their channels the next phase
is that we as Google test those drivers
those software's in our lab to make sure
they work well with anthos environment
and things work seamlessly and at that
point they get a choice to say should we
distribute those through the vendor
infrastructure or should we distribute
those specifically like software-defined
vendors and also like drivers for
appliance vendors to redistribute them
through marketplace which gives
customers a lot more seamless unified
experience eventually as the program
matures we really want to get to a point
we are pre-packaging certain sets of
drivers in the bundle so that gives one
less click or one less step for the
customers and it's the experience is a
lot more seamless with this I'll invite
parts on the stage to talk more about so
the customer challenges and use cases
Thank You mano so before I get started
maybe it's a show of hands how many of
you are running stateful workloads on
containers today our communities today
it's pretty impressive actually
if you think about it just last year I
would say that very few people are out
of trade their hands and this is
actually ongoing trend anyway with that
so Who am I and what am I talking about
today and what am I doing here
so as a way of introduction my name is
Bart a settler and I'm the co-founder
and CTO of Robyn dot IO and we are
partners with Google on the anthos
platform now a little bit about the
company so we the mission of the company
was to enable our customers to run
mission-critical stateful workloads on
containers and by extension kubernetes
so when I say stateful locals what does
it mean I mean it could be just a small
Jenkins job with persistent volumes
underneath it but when we looked at the
market the real pain if you will was
around the more complex platforms such
as big data platforms or at Cloudera
elasticsearch Splunk or of course the no
sequel platform such as [ __ ] and
Cassandra and couch yeah and even
traditional RDBMS solutions like posters
Oracle RAC Hana and all that right and
it's kind of surprising if you look at
it nobody really associates the word
Oracle RAC with kubernetes but we have
production deployments of that so I
think it's safe to say that we know a
thing or two about how you can run these
applications on con kubernetes and what
are the real challenges that somebody's
going to see when you when you actually
manage them the one point I do want to
highlight is based on the experience of
the type of workloads that we have been
able to onboard on to communities we
have brought this expertise of how you
take all of this stuff and then package
it into a set of api's that your code
alert with Google to give to the
community and
hope here is that this would become like
what sequel did to structured query this
would do to data management on
kubernetes for stateful apps and that is
the thing that we want in this API sets
to be something that a lot of other
partners will also embrace but the what
you're going to see today is the API
specs and the demo of how it how it
looks like but before you go there right
so what is so different about running
stateful workloads why why do you even
how to talk about this as a main topic
right so a couple of things here right
so unlike a stateless workloads which is
very ephemeral and the value scale it is
very different then let's say database
where you just don't add more pods and
take them away because they are cost
associated with data
redistributions and all that so that's
on the deployment side but once deployed
unlike a stateless application a
stateful one has a very long life and
people are used to doing data management
on that and when I say data management
it's usually around data protection
whether it is snapshots or backups or it
is around data collaborations along with
their apps things like clones and all
that right but for the folks in the room
who have come from the storage
background these are not new terms when
everybody understands these things but
the world is very different today in the
previous world all these things were
usually done by the storage
administrator in today's world in a
kubernetes world it's done by developers
and DevOps and they are not necessarily
storage experts and it's very hard for
them to comprehend what it means to go
snapshot a LAN and what it means to go
and clone it right so what do you really
need to do is elevate this entire
experience into an application construct
so that developers can go and say I have
a [ __ ] that I've spun up either through
an operator or through hell I'm going to
go snapshot I don't want to back it up
but I want to port it from one data
center to the other now I'm going to go
a little deeper into what it means to do
those things and I'm also going to use a
few of our real-life customer
experiences and what pains a customer
and how he had solved them so the first
thing is around data protection so you
want to basically keep a copy of your
application and its data in such a way
that there is a corruption you can
easily roll back to a more cleaner or
pristine State now there are two ways to
do it and it's really important to kind
of capture both of them and talk about
the differences
there's this notion of snapshots which
is usually a very enriching and snapshot
your entire application on the same disk
on which it is from which it is serving
or the data and then there is a thing
called backup where you basically take
these snapshots and then move it up into
the cloud so both of them serve two
different needs right however if you
look at today's challenges the way you
will do this let's say you're running
just take a very simple example pose
dress right if you are doing posters
today you would have to go and tell your
storage administrator that hill is an i
garage snapshot my storage lungs they
would snapshot that but then what you
just have a snapshot at Lund what the
what the developer will want to do is
they would want to go and snapshot not
just the storage volumes but all the
metadata around that storage volume
which would be obviously the PVCs then
things like config maps then stateful
sets services secrets all of that
because all of that essentially forms
your application and once you can
capture that as an application snapshot
then you can enable workflows such as
creating a quick clone or migrating it
to the to a different data center and
things like the next one is around clone
so maybe a use case from one of our
Oracle RAC customers so it's a large
trows bookings company they run Oracle
RAC as a service on robben and one one
of the use case that they have is their
DBAs at the end of every quarter they
have to run reports and they don't want
to go and run those reports on the
production database so what do they do
they go to this platform and they say
I'm going to create a query quick clone
and they create a clone it's not again
as I said it's not a storage clone it is
a fully functional running Oracle RAC
instance with data as off the previous
snapshot that was taken another use case
for clone would be to validate patches
and updates nobody wants to go and write
run a patch or an upgrade on the
production database how do you like to
create a clone run it there validate if
everything is fine then you would go in
apply it right so those are the kind of
use cases that you can enable and make
it much more easy to consume in this
world of kubernetes by elevating isn't
Erik's experience to applications and
the last interesting use case that I
would like to capture as app portability
and what I mean by that is more and
you see that developers want to liberate
their applications and data from the
underlying infrastructure choices you
might start today on premises let's say
Ornette WS but you would like to go
migrate tomorrow into Google cloud
because you have resources there that
you really want to use maybe you want to
use TP use there right so you want to
have the ability to go and migrate your
entire application not just the storage
volumes that's incredibly difficult
because each data center each cloud has
a different way in which that does
storage and networking and all that so
you go to abstract it out in such a way
that you can very easily migrate things
now so with this this I mean these are
the kind of experiences that we have
been able to give to our to our
customers on kubernetes and this is the
experience that we have shared and we
have co-developed this api is with a
deep integration with the dantos storage
team so what does it mean how would a
partner's life look like once you have
embraced these api sets so I'm going to
show you what we have done at Robin so
let's look at this on the left-hand side
before today maybe right before you hear
what is what I'm going to see on the
right the way you deploy or settle
stateful workload is either you would
use the standard queue portal interface
and use llamo or you will use a Helen
chart to deploy it oh you might use an
operator if one exists right so there is
nothing different this is very standard
way of doing things but this is just
provisioning what you need beyond this
would be something like this right there
you can go and do an entire snapshot of
your Postgres let's say Helen release
right aren't running instance of your
operator or you can clone it you can
push it from on premises to GCS right
and then from GCS you'll be able to
drain it back into a different region so
think about the power of this right GCS
is an object store positive sits on a
block store so what do you mean what
what you're doing here is from one data
center or one region you're taking a
snapshot you're pushing the snapshot
from block the snapshot sets on block
you push the snapshot from block and do
GCS which is object and you can go to a
completely different region and using GC
uses global distribution right of
objects you can go to a completely
different region and rehydrate
data from block from object into block
and offer it as an application running
application now imagine the power of
this right so that is what this API said
is going to do and we're hoping that
this does truly become the sequel of
data management and we are very honored
to be part of this effort
with Google with that I will hand it off
to Orlick C for showing you a demo and
going into the technical details Thank
You parson hello my name is Ashok I'm a
software engineer in an tha's storage
team and okay so let's take a look at
the architecture the high-level
architecture so here you can see that we
introduced a couple of new components to
kubernetes G and every component is
represented by this red block which is a
component controller and the arrows
pointing towards that block represent
API for the controller api's are defined
as kubernetes custom resource
definitions CR DS and you can notice
that these components are nicely layered
one on top of the other so and so the
component of the top can be leveraged
functionality of the component on the
bottom so let's take a look at the
individual components so the volume
group controller and API is responsible
for taking crash consistence crash
consistent evolving group snapshots and
backups it talks to you CSI driver for
to to run some storage level commands
like take a snapshot create a backup
restore a volume from the snapshot or
backup and it uses GCS it uses GCS to
store to export the backups so the next
component is application controller and
API and application control and API are
responsible for taking application level
application consistent snapshots and
backups which include both persistent
data and application metadata
and we use an application backup
management service to keep as a global
register for our backups so the backups
could be used across different
kubernetes clusters and the third
component is application policy
controller and API which is responsible
for scheduling and retention application
level snapshots and backups given some
policies okay at this point I wanted to
just step back and explain how we model
our API is what it's what is the API
structure and what is the responsibility
of each piece of the API so we model our
API the same way as kubernetes models
persistent volumes and per system volume
snapshots which means we use a
controller claim and content triplets so
and their class represents provides
portability across clusters and it
contains it refers to the specific
controller or handler to handle claims
and it also contains some configuration
for controllers say some secret keys or
some player like a fake parameters for
controllers and class usually is
provided by kubernetes administrators
the next one is a claim which is
provided by user and actually it's a
request for action like take a snapshot
create a backup and the content is the
actual result of the controller
processing the claim
so like snapshot was taken here is a
snapshot ID okay so in this demo we'll
mostly talking about application
component and now we are going to
actually I'm going to just explain the
components API and see are these we use
in this component so first one is
stateful application which defines an
application which has some persistence
state you can use this CRD when you want
to just refer to your existing
application and later you can refer
the stateful application when you take
snapshot or backup or you can create
stateful application and refer to
existing snapshot or backup in order to
control to actually provision your an
application based on the snapshot and
backup the next one is the application
snapshot which represent the application
snapshot like State stored in the local
storage and when we say state means it
both persistent data plus metadata this
year G can be used in two cases when you
want to actually a snapshot exists an
application in your cluster or if you
want to import external back up to the
local storage application backup it
represents the application state stored
in external storage like GCS for example
again here we are talking about state
which is represented by both persistent
data plus metadata and application
backups are used either to backup
running application war in order to
export the local snapshot to external
storage application rollback is defines
a user request to just roll back exist
an application to previously taken
snapshot or backup ok here comes the
demo can I go back to slides
so I just wanted to like touched upon
the use cases which you're going to
cover in the demo so first use case is
rolled back an application after
unsuccessful upgrade and the second one
we're gonna migrate the stapled workload
from from on-premise kubernetes cluster
to the cloud kubernetes cluster which is
in our case gke the demo setup so we
actually have two kubernetes clusters
one is running on Prem
by G key on Prem and we run it on VMware
and use the robinus and the
software-defined storage in the cloud we
use gke as a provider of kubernetes
cluster and to be used we also use robin
software-defined storage for our running
type of persistent disks our application
consists of two components is the UI
which for simplicity we represent as a
simple sequel pad application which is
like just web-based sequel tool and
persistent state is stored in Postgres
which around a master slave mode and
just to maybe add you some color about
the application so let's assume this is
as sales application we run for our
company's sales but for the purpose of
the demo we will only take a look at the
part of the application which which is
responsible for handling cost customers
okay with that we can switch to the
console thank you
okay so now I'm in the console where we
console on-prem which you can tell by
this little blue arrow at the bottom I
can I will switch from the on-prem to
the cloud when we need it for the second
use case I prepared a set of scripts
batch scripts most of they are only like
it's just they wrap the cube cut all
commands so before running it every
script I'm going to show its content so
we are in the same page and explain its
what does it do what it does and yeah so
let's take a look at the application
which is running in the on-prem cluster
so we see a dimension is a sales
application which consists of two parts
the first one is the kubernetes of
Postgres running master/slave mode and
the actual UI we have here so let's take
a look at the UI and the content and
what we have and the data we have in the
database
so we have customers table which has for
every customer we have first name last
name email and company so let's run some
prerequisites first prerequisites script
let me show you what it has in this
script we just deploy applications
snapshot class and application backup
class in the snapshot class we define
that Robin is going to hand Robins can
handle the snapshots and we say that
and here we defined also application I
mean Postgres quiescent uncurious hooks
so we are able to take application
consistent snapshots in the backup class
we define just the backup handler who's
going to handle our backups okay let's
run the script
so the next step would be we have a run
in application now let's create a
stateful application on top of it so we
are going to round the second script
where we define the stateful application
and we refer to the sales application
which we are currently running so now
we're going to wait a little bit until
controller sees that request and
fulfills it okay so we are registered
stateful application in the controller
okay so now it's time for the first use
case it's rollback after unsuccessful
upgrade so yeah so here the story assume
you have like p.m. coming approaching
you like p.m. let's let just say like my
new asked me to specifically say it's
not him so it's not Manu yeah so we are
in the same page yeah so where was I
yeah so Manu approaches me and says like
okay so we a sales team has new
requirements and they want actually to
extend our live the way women maintain
the company's data so now we have
company name only as part of the
customer but they want to actually
extend that functionality and maintain
more information about company so and I
said yeah that's cool I need three days
for that this is nice you have one day I
got a go bike ok now we have one day to
actually do two changes right we need to
change the UI and we need to actually
provide a change to the database schema
so we can extract the informed us temir
stable we need we need to extract the
informational company and put that into
separate table ok so I have I prepared
an upgrade script for that but
considering that it didn't have much
time for testing right and it's usually
it's like database schema change is
usually pretty dangerous so we are going
to take
snapshot first of the existing
application let me show you what we do
so we are creating an application
snapshot and refer to the application
the stateful application which we are
currently running which we register in
the previous step
okay so controller start started working
on it
so just to stress it so when we say like
take an application snapshot and take an
application backup we are taking we are
talking about both persistent data and
metadata okay
snapshot is ready ever since ready for
the upgrade so let's do the upgrade okay
this is our current state of the
application as you see we use UI version
1 and we are going to grade it to
version 0 to version 2 and the errors
are the rest of the application so we
have we are ready to continue here the
script which will be which will perform
the actual database upgrade schema
upgrade so are you sure yes I am
okay let's wait for the upgrade it's
gonna be really soon done okay so now
please notice that we have UI version
2.0 running and let's give some time for
the application to settle down so it's
still like UI is terminating yeah okay
so upgrade I would say it was successful
right no error let's take a look at the
data
right you can see that now we have three
tables not only one so let's take a look
at the company's table right so company
names we're like successfully
transferred from the customers table to
the new table let's take a look at
customers okay
yeah please notice what happened instead
of like during upgrade instead of
extracting the company and then deleting
this column I actually deleted the email
column from the table but fortunately we
have our snapshot right so now we are
able to roll back our application the
previous state fix the upgrade script
and run it again
so now let's roll back the application
so I'm going to run this script which
defines the rollback points to the sales
stateful application and the sources use
a snapshot which we took on the previous
step so let's do throw back so they're
all back we'll take a little bit longer
because as a rollback we understand of
its it's complete full application
rollback including it's like pods and
everything because metadata was also
stored so as part of this upgrade will
again switch back from UI version 2 to
UI version 1 so now you see that all the
pods are terminating so we need to wait
until they are all terminated and they
will be replaced with the snapshot
version of these application so UI is
always behind
okay okay okay done so the new version
is terminated and now you'll see that
the older one the snapshot version will
actually start spinning up
here okay so please know that now UI is
version 1.0 so it's a previous version
of our UI and soon we're gonna have all
the pots running and ready and so we can
go back to the database and see what's
in there okay let's take a look at the
database
you see now we have only one table and
all our information is back so including
emails so now we can fix the upgrade and
run it again so this concludes our first
eat first news case and the second use
case is is going to be my gradient of
state of workflow from on-premise
coverage cluster to gke so as a first
step we need to actually now we have a
local snapshot right we took before the
upgrade now we need to actually make
this snapshot available for the external
cluster for that to do that we actually
export the snapshot to including data
and metadata to GCS using this script so
we are created application backup as a
source we provide a snapshot which we
too can approve one of the previous
steps and the target location we say is
GCS bucket and the secret we provide you
get to give controller access to the
bucket so let's run the script
usually taking backups may have take
time because it's like we transfer data
from local storage to remote one but in
our case we don't have a lot of data and
usually storage providers they support
incremental backups which means once you
upload it like full backup the next
version of next updates to the backup
will be just incremental so only the
deltas will be sent so done so okay the
backup was exported and we have this
backup ID which will need later to
actually import information about the
backup on the gke cluster okay let's
switch to GK I'm going to switch the
cube shuttle context to GK then let's
take a look what we have indicator
nothing that's good exactly what we need
and yeah so the first step now when we
are in GK cluster we want to import
knowledge about the external backup to
internal kubernetes cluster so for that
we'll need the ID I was actually let's
take a look first the import script so
as you see we are going to create the
application backup which refers to the
external handle it's the ID we obtained
in the previous step when we export it
at the backup and as a location for
where we take the data is GCS bucket
which is the same as in the previous
step so let's copy the ID from here and
let's go to the cloud and from the
script
okay so now we see that information
about the external backup was imported
successfully and pretty fast the reason
it's so fast because we don't actually
import data we import only knowledge
about the backup so and though the next
step you're going to actually rehydrate
the app stateful application from the
backup so I'm gonna run this script
which will create a stateful application
and I specify the source I specify
backup which this cluster already knows
about and just say create this stateful
application top of that based on that
okay oh so now we see that application
is being imported so and we can notice
that it's UI version 1.0 it's the same
one we used with a snapshot and yeah
let's wait for the actual cluster 2
application to become ready
yeah my cheeky cluster is behind
firewall so I don't have direct access
to nodes of the GK cluster so for that
reason I'm going to need to do some SSH
for reading port forwarding I'm going to
use this node port to forward it to my
local machine
yeah so basically I port for i-4 at this
port which we took the previous step to
the local port 2009 T okay and let's go
back to the cloud and see okay
so import it so applications up and
running let's take a look at the data
so it'll support different port okay
something's there I'm gonna use cloud
and select from customers yeah
unfortunately there is some issue with
networking and GK I saw it previously so
but I know how to fix it so that's a
good news
we just need to bounce a UI and it work
it's gonna work so I have a script here
which just says restart cloud game I you
is so it's just what I'm doing here is
just basically bouncing the demo app UI
it's it's also possible okay yeah let's
let's now see again
let's try it one more time and there is
another cuher to that it's not talked to
the service but talked to the pod
directly so I'm not like don't need to
fix that in GK
okay so yeah so it's just intermittent
networking problems yeah yeah
you saw it yeah yes so yeah sometimes it
didn't work even when I was you know at
home like doing the demo so I'm not
surprised it doesn't work before like
such large audience so it's kind of
expected yes that's a good point
I forgot it but I agree with that okay
yeah thank you
perfect thank you so much
[Music]